>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Gail Shirazi: I'm Gail Shirazi
at the Israel Judaic
Section here at the Library.
Welcome to today's program.
Girl, a book talk by Alona Frankel.
Before we start a few announcements.
Number one, please turn
off your cell phones.
And number two, this event is going
to be webcast so if you do not wish
to appear in the webcast,
please exit during the
question and answer period.
The event today is co-sponsored
by the Young Reader Center,
the European Division, the Hebrew
Language Table in cooperation
with the Embassy of Israel
and the [inaudible] Chair
Forum of GW University.
I would like to thank all the
participating organizations,
a special thanks to the Young
Reader Center, to Audrey Fisher
and the Public Affairs Office,
Naheen Gerstein [phonetic]
and Galena Tavaroski [phonetic], the
IJ Section and a very special thanks
to Delphine Gamburg [phonetic]
and the Embassy of Israel,
Ari Frankel [phonetic], and our very
special presenter, Alona Frankel.
Alona is an award winning
Israeli author and illustrator.
She is best known for her
classic work, Once Upon a Potty,
which has been translated into many,
many languages including
Spanish, Japanese amongst others.
Her late husband, Zygmunt Frankel,
was a well known artist and writer,
and her son, Ari, has illustrated
and written children's books
and is an accomplished musician.
Alona is gifting to the
Library 82 pieces of material.
On the [inaudible], we
have a presentation later
on to the librarian's office
and there's just a
sampling of her books here.
Today she will be speaking about
the newly translated book, Girl.
Alona, like her books, is bright,
positive and a delight to be with.
She speaks of rainbow, love, stars,
grandparents on the farm
and white elephants.
I'm amazed how someone that
has experienced such sadness
in life creates and gives
happiness to so many of us.
When I think of Alona and
her work, a paraphrase line
from the Yiddish Culture
[inaudible] Project,
which we had here last
week, comes to mind.
Power of art, resiliency of the
human spirit and the will to live.
Thank you, Alona, for giving
us all of these gifts.
Before Alona speaks, we have a few
words of welcome from the Chief
of Diplomacy at the Embassy
of Israel, Yaron Gamburg.
Yaron.
[ Applause ]
>> Yaron Gamburg: Thank you, Gail.
I'm not exactly Chief of Diplomacy.
I wish I were, but my position
is Administer of Public Diplomacy
at the Embassy of Israel.
I took on this position a few
months ago and it's a pleasure,
it's a pleasure and honor to be
with you, all of you this morning,
this afternoon, the Alona Frankel
colleagues from the Library
of Congress, dear Gail, once again.
Today Alona will be speaking
with us about her book,
newly translated book
into English, Girl.
Her own experiences as a young
girl during the Holocaust.
Last week on November
9th, we remembered one
of the more tragic days
of the modern history the
Kristallnacht on November 9.
This event was actually a precursor
of the Holocaust when dozens
of Jews were killed, synagogues
and Jewish-owned stores
and institutions were burned.
There was a special
congressional event
at the Washington Hebrew
Congregation together
with also the Chinese embassy.
I must tell you that as a grandson
of a Holocaust survivor myself
and also as the grandson
of the officer
in the Red Army before
the Nazis this period
of history has a special personal
meaning for me and this book
of Alona provides us with
a very important insight
into the children's mind and
soul in the period of our history
when hatred and bigotry
became dominant models
of too many governments
and political leaders
in Europe and elsewhere.
It's a must read for all of
us for all of those who have
as adults responsibility for
our lives, for our own reality,
for our children by what
we say and what we do.
This book of Alona is written
for adults but let us not forget
that most of the books
Alona wrote in the past more
than 40 years were for children.
So did you know about the
family of tiny white elephants?
[Speaking Hebrew] in Hebrew.
In Hebrew it sounds better.
Yes or no.
Let me give you a trailer.
In the jungle there lives a family
of little white elephants
[speaking Hebrew] in Hebrew.
Papa [inaudible], Mama
[inaudible] and baby [inaudible]
and one day this happy
family is joined
by a tiny baby girl
elephant, [inaudible].
And I will not give a
spoiler for those of you
who still haven't read this book,
but I will tell you it is
my favorite book of Alona.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, I will get your
signature later.
[Laughter] So this book, when I
read this book to my oldest son
after his baby brother was born and
while he was happy in general but,
you know, he was not too much
eager to share his stories
with his brother, you know, and
Alona's book was the best guide
for me, my wife in educating
our children to love each other.
For me today there's a special
opportunity to meet in person
with Alona and thank her in
person for this wonderful world
that she created for
us for our kids.
This world where we
can educate each other,
where we can understand
each other and this world
where we can learn how we can
and should love each other.
Later afternoon as Gail said Alona's
work and legacy will be honored
by the Library of Congress.
It's a wonderful gift to her as
a writer but it's also a gift
to [inaudible] literature
in general,
to the modern Hebrew
language literature.
This language that was
revived only 100 years ago
when nobody believed the [inaudible]
succeed except for a small bunch
of people like [inaudible]
and a few others.
So Alona's books like books of other
modern Israeli writers are a vivid
illustration of this revival.
Modern Hebrew combines the
depths of the ancient language
and at the same time allows us
to communicate the most
sophisticated concepts
of contemporary civilization.
So this triumph of modern
Hebrew is one of the sources
of this incredible achievements of
Israeli culture in general be it
in literature, theatre or cinema.
Speaking about cinema just
check these movies on Netflix
to get an idea of the scope.
So, thank you very much
for this attention.
I wish us all a great book
talk by Alona Frankel.
Thank you.
[Speaking Hebrew]
[ Applause ]
>> Alona Frankel: Hi, I'm
Alona, and I'm really very proud
to be invited here and talk to you.
I shall try as briefly as
possible, which isn't easy,
to tell you about this book of
mine, which I wrote after many years
that I wrote and illustrate the
books for children and as modest
as I am I must confess that my books
were very, very nice appreciated
and well-known and they got many
prizes, and I could never imagine
that I would write about my history
of my childhood that happened
in the worst times in our history,
the Jewish history,
and I was part of it.
So I am what is called a Holocaust
survivor and it's kind of a conflict
because usually such subjects
they got stereotypes how Holocaust
survivor has to look like.
So usually it has to be very
ugly and then he has to be
with some ash [phonetic] on his
head and all kinds of movements.
So it's such a thing that
I always try to look nice.
So, I'm like misleading people,
oh, you're a Holocaust survivor,
it's impossible but it is all true.
I was born in an unfortunate
era just 2 years, in 1937,
just 2 years before the
Germans occupied Poland.
I was born in Poland in
a wonderful city Krakow.
If you have been in Poland or plan
to be, you have to visit this place.
It's really wonderful.
And in 1939 the Germans as you must
know invaded Poland and my father,
my mother and me we escaped
to the east to a city
by the name of Lvov [phonetic].
The city now is [inaudible]
and escaped from Germans.
Of course no one then knew
what is going to happen
and there were many Jews that
prefer the German occupation
than the Russia occupation
because the German was, of course,
well-known as very
cultured civilization
and the Russians were always
like lower kind of culture.
So many stayed and they,
of course, were murdered,
but we also couldn't
escape the German invasion.
It was a period that
[inaudible] make kind
of a pact that they divide Poland.
It's a very difficult
place that Poland exists.
I mean the borders.
In the west, the Germans, east,
the Russians so in their history,
which is really horrible history,
3 times this nation even didn't
exist being divided between Poland,
between Russia and Germany
and Austria in the south.
So after they win the war
between Russia and German started,
the Germans came to Lvov and to
begun a history that everyone knows
that they established the ghetto
and all the Jews were forced
to leave during the most poor part
of the city and all those atrocities
that happened, the actions and
even actions against children.
They are worse that when I hear them
that immediately get kind of alert
like [inaudible] selections
that started
to have this whole
new meaning for me.
So I usually avoid
them and what started
in the ghetto were those
actions even against children.
Only recently I heard just
horrible thing that the Germans
in the ghetto they
established some playground
to make children gather
there and then they took them
and all of them were murdered.
So, I am one of very few children
that survived from this Lvov ghetto.
When it turned out that the
ghetto is going to be liquidated,
which is also a word that
always make me, you know, jump,
so my parents tried very much
to find some place to escape
and to find some place to hide.
And they did find some place.
A family that owned, this man owned
the, was very grateful for my father
and they agreed to hide them,
but without a child, imagine.
So I was the child.
So it was another problem
what to do with the child.
So it was a woman that agreed
to take me to her parents
in a very small village
named [inaudible]
and they made some false documents
and my mother was even told me,
look, Elonka, my name is Alona, my
real name is Alona, look, Elonka,
your name is not Alona, your
name is name Irina [phonetic]
and not Goodwin [phonetic],
which is my family name,
Seraman [phonetic], Irina Seraman.
And she told me all these Christian
prayers say our Lord in heaven
and everything and how to, you
know, all those men, Saints,
and it was very lucky
because my accent was Polish.
We were [inaudible] and didn't
speak, I don't understand Yiddish
so it was Polish so
this what happened
that all the family they
told me I am a Christian girl
and this woman she came
to take me to the village.
So, now I want to show you
how, which one is, which one?
This is my son, Ari.
Okay, okay.
So, my mother was born in a
little town named Oswiecim,
which became during the war
Auschwitz and here you see them
like nice Jew and there's
my grandmother.
He name was Rebecca.
And she was known for her beauty.
There were stories that during the
first World War Cossacks [inaudible]
just to look at her, which is nice.
And after the war no one
knew how, where to find them
and they were not anymore.
And this is me.
As I told you, I was born in Krakow.
My mother she told me that I was so
ugly that when she walked with me
to the park when the
[inaudible] didn't come,
she used to put me
near one bench and sit
in the second one just
not make connection.
[Laughter] I don't
think I am so ugly here.
So, this is also me.
Nice. So after my parents hide in
this place with this Polish family
and I was in the village, the ghetto
was liquidate and they also were
that as this meaning that I cannot
repeat and I was in the village
and until now I just can't
imagine how it happened
that a small girl is taken from her
parents, her name changed and she
so quickly learned those players,
which are very nice and took
to a remote village with 2
extremely old people they were
like 45 something like this.
So imagine I was born in 1937
so half a year I will be 80.
I must tell you it's
completely new thing
in my life I cannot understand
it how, when it become
that it was just whole
life what did I do?
It's like this amount of life
and now it's so little left.
I am really sorry because it's
such a waste of time to die.
[Laughter] Life is so interesting.
But, well, that's it.
So in the ghetto here I will show
you some things and some documents
that my mother kept under
the mattress and, of course,
after she died I have them.
And some of them are, this is one
of the documents from the ghetto
if you see my father already
looks horrible and this is some
in our ghetto even to say
our ghetto it's horrible.
So, it wasn't the Yellow Star of
David, it was kind of a ribbon
on your shoulder that you are Jewish
and those are some permissions
that you can, that you work.
So one of them it [inaudible].
My father was very good
at making false documents,
but I do not really know which one
and here is this woman that agreed
to hide me with her parents.
Her name was Hannah Seraman
[phonetic] and she had terrible name
because she was kind of
making deals all the time.
You know when war, when such a
situation is a horrible war it takes
place so there are
many elements of people
that suddenly they become
cooperating with the conqueror
and making all kind of
deals between the Gestapo
and the Jews and the Poles.
So she had this name that
she was like really terrible
because she promised some families
to hide them and it was known
that she took them and then she took
all their money and abandoned them
of course to certain death.
But still she didn't do it with me.
So, if you see I am, my parents
paid for, paid her to take me
and if you see this photograph
this dress my mother did it
and this ribbon after we
have been in this photograph.
So it was taken from me and this,
they asked her to photograph me
because they really didn't
believe that I am still alive
and in this hiding to convince
my parents that I am still alive
so they ask her to give me some
piece of paper for me to draw
because they didn't and then
after she bring the drawing
they gave her the money
and here you see really did the kind
of drawings I was doing here it's
like me and piece of a car and
the dog and this is a train.
I don't know if someone were to
come now and show me those drawings
and ask me what do you predict
from this child to be maybe,
illustrator or something?
No. No, they are not
such talented drawings.
[Laughter] So, but still it is
really, it is really interesting
and then those drawings
somehow saved my life
and now these being
illustrator I make my living.
So it's like a chain of the same
talent helped me then and now.
And here is also a
drawing if you can see it.
This is supposed to be [inaudible]
and farmers with those, you know,
I don't know how you call it
in English those, you know,
that you cut the grass
and the wheat.
So those are the drawings my parents
got and then gave her some money.
After the money it was no more.
They didn't have any
money to pay her anymore.
So, she abandoned me.
She took me back to this hiding
where my parents were hiding
in Lvov and, of course, as I told
you this family didn't want a child
to be there.
Imagine no children,
no pets, no children.
And still she took me to the hiding
of my parents, which was a very,
very small room that
once was a cabinet
of a [inaudible] a Jewish doctor,
and here is his mother and his wife
and the children were murdered
in the beginning of the war
and now this family lived there.
And it was a small room and I
was not allowed to talk loudly
and to walk in case any
neighbors will notice
that Jews are hiding there because
it's very important to realize
that only Poland it was a
death penalty for hiding Jews.
So, and only Poland I
am kind of taking care
of their reputation somehow
because I love Poland
so much and I love the language.
So, in Poland, they didn't
cooperate with the Germans
like every other occupied country,
Belgium and France and Hungary
and Romania and every other country.
The Poles always were
opposed and many millions
of Poles also were murdered during
this war and it doesn't mean
that there were also many
[inaudible] that gave away the Jews
and sometimes for money and
sometimes because they didn't
like us so much, which
is really strange.
I think it's kind of a
disease like necrophilia
or something it's so disgusting.
I really cannot understand.
Well, but this is another subject.
So in this hiding where
I was not allowed to talk
and I think also food was very
not, it's difficult to talk about
but it [inaudible] situation that
me I was hiding from those people
that hide my parents and all of us
were hiding from the [inaudible]
and when the steps of this lady
was approaching like this so I had
to run to the corner of this little
place and hide under the rocks there
that we slept there and
being quiet like mice.
By the way I had my pets.
There were 2 little mouse,
mice, one of them was name Misha
and the other one Tisha
and I tamed them.
They came and I made them for little
crumbs of bread that were left food
and when the front was near and
they were bombarding the city,
so of course, everyone in
the city went to a shelter
and the mice always also
run away but we couldn't
because when the neighbors
would see us Jews so we stayed
in this little place
during the bombardment.
And in this little place, every
piece of paper which was very,
very rare so I draw and
it's really unbelievable.
I really don't understand it
how a girl being there can make
such drawings like
little fairies and dwarf
and this [inaudible] birds closed in
a little room, no food, no walking,
no speaking but it's,
this is how it was.
And then I did the drawings
and this one if you see
so everyone here is smoking because
they were, of course, no food,
no cigarettes and they don't
know where was more important
for my parents and as you
see, everyone here is smoking.
They were smoking and the boys
smoking and the chimney smoking,
which is a very good sign because
if there's smoke out of the stove,
a chimney, it means maybe
something is cooking there.
So, they pick mushrooms
and so idyllic
and I a little girl hide in there.
And here it's also some of the
things that survived the war.
This is a cookbook that my
mother dictate to my father
because he has very nice handwriting
and it's also [inaudible]
because she made this cookbook.
Imagine those times that no meal is
repeating itself during the whole
year like the first and second
and the dessert and every place
that was left so I was
making those drawings.
And here this is another story.
All those documents and
there are much more are now
in the Washington Museum,
Holocaust Museum.
Of course when Israel have
this museum [inaudible]
that I must confess I don't
like this institution, sorry.
Why I don't like it because
somehow it's a very political.
Every guest that is coming to
Israel first of all take them
to the [inaudible] and it's like,
you know, those beggars in front
of a Cathedral they see it and
they [inaudible] bleeding heart.
So I feel like the government is
taking advantage on back of people
like me that survived this
war and they were very,
very offended when I decided
to give those documents
because they started to [inaudible].
So I gave it to the
museum here in Washington.
In [inaudible] in this
hiding, were some books,
which is really very strange
because this book is the
first edition of [inaudible].
I must have some took
care of [inaudible]
and this first edition my
father bought, of course,
everyone in [inaudible] knew
German so, and because he read it
and because he knew
that it's written
in such a [inaudible] German
language, the intellectual,
so he never believed that
this man will succeed
to do something politically, which
was of course a huge mistake.
So imagine they run
away from the Germans
and they took the book with them.
It's really so, so
unbelievable and other books was,
that was in this hiding was a
wonderful huge book of the history
of the Jesuits, which was
very important [inaudible]
of declaration.
It was also a Bible, first edition
like 100 years old, in English
and beautiful letters of Hebrew and
my father used to tell me stories
from the Bible and I
remember the stories I
like the most were first the
stories about Noah and the ark,
you know Noah and the ark
that he saved the animals
before the [inaudible].
And what I liked about it first of
all they had enough food and, well,
now I think about it it's
strange because lions
and sheep I don't know maybe
they feed on each other
but this is not a nice
story so forget it.
And then it was the smell of wood
that this little place would
camouflage as a carpenter workshop
for I like the story of the
[inaudible] and, of course,
they survive it which was really and
the other story that I like most was
about the story of the man, man
[inaudible] that God gave people
of Israel from the
sky and it was shape
of some cardinal [phonetic]
something and you eat it
and then you can imagine every
kind of food that you like,
like strawberries and cream
or ice cream and so on.
So, of course, in this situation I
like the stories very, very much.
The other book also was because
it was a cabinet of a gynecologist
so it was an encyclopedia in 5
volumes of the sexual science.
So imagine I being a children
illustrator, of course,
those were the first [inaudible]
I have seen in my life.
[Laughter] It's kind of ironic
and five volumes there were
and it's also here in
the Washington Museum.
And then it was a cookbook.
A cookbook that they also took
when they run away to the east
and this cookbook my father gave my
mother on her birthday as a present.
I must tell you she never
forgive my father because instead
of some French perfume or some
negligee, pink or maybe sexy black,
I don't know if then it
was sex at all and black
and so she never forgive him.
So if you imagine those books were
about the most important things
of life because, well,
cookbook, foods, yes?
A religion, you have the Jesuits
and the Bible and, of course,
politics was the main
[inaudible], yes.
And also what was there
a lot of book, of course,
so the most important
thing in life and then
after the war my mother
kept those books.
And here I want to show you
this, some of the photographs.
Some of the photographs
of members of my family
that didn't survive the war and
no one knew what happened to them,
but they were not anymore.
I decided because of those
photographs I decided
to write this book, Girl,
because still then I was writing
and illustrating and as
[inaudible] as I am I must confess
that I was very successful.
I get a lot of prizes and usually
those prizes were some kind
of a paper written calligraphy very
nice, Alona Frankel get the first,
and this was the prize and my mother
used to keep it under her mattress
and then I kept it under
the mattress and then
when my mother died I took
care of her many years
and she died she was 90 1/2.
It's only when I think
about it if I am 80
so another 10 1/2 years
it's very near.
I really can't accept it.
Really it's not, well, she
finds some moments and she died.
And I had to arrange her apartment
after she died and whoever had
to do it in his life I must tell
you this is one of the worst things
that can happen to a person.
You come to the place
of your childhood
and you find there yourself
and I found all kinds
of presents I gave my mother
and she even didn't open them.
She said, oh, Elonka, you waste
your money and when you come
to [inaudible] the merchandise
you feel like clapping his hands
and saying, oh, this
is such an easy prey
and you pay 10 times
more, which is right.
I cannot argue or I go away, but
I didn't argue about the price.
And then among other things I
found, I found a shoe box, you know.
Usually it's very suitable to have,
to take a photograph and I looked
through those photographs and they
were not survive the war with us.
They were my aunt here,
not here, there in Israel
and my aunt she was the
only person that survived
because she came to
Israel in the 30s.
And she had those photographs of the
members of the family and they look
at those pictures and they feel so
guilty because I really didn't want
to hear about those histories
that my mother used to tell
because I always felt
so guilty about it.
It happens that when someone
survives some horrible,
horrible situation and so he feel
guilty that fate is ruling his life
but why me, why I am one of so few
children that survive the ghetto
in Lvov and why this woman didn't
just abandon me somewhere no one
will ever know.
So, I didn't like to talk,
to hear it and I didn't,
but still I realized that I'm the
last person in the world that can,
that knows some of the names
of those people and then I felt
like maybe I have to
somehow to tell the story
because it was never a secret that
I was during the war in Poland.
Israel to be a new
immigrant from Poland it's not
such a big honor especially
to be a Polish mother
or a Polish woman it's
not, it is not a big honor.
Really I don't know why because I am
such a nice person
so I don't know why.
And then I decided when I started,
when I grew up and then I was
in the Army [phonetic], of
course, I was very important.
I was in the Air Force intelligence.
I must tell you I was a surgeon.
I must confess that I
still know some secrets
that I will never,
ever, ever tell you.
And after I was married very young
and then I had Ari and, you know,
immediately the thing will change
your life for the rest of it is
when you become a parent.
So, and I started to
work, of course,
and just didn't have time
to deal with this past.
I didn't want to.
I run away from it.
And the other thing was that
they didn't want my children
to be second generation
of Holocaust survivor.
I wanted them just to adore me
because I am a really an excellent
mother and the best mother
in the world and not because
they pity me that I had
such a horrible childhood.
My other son, Ari, is a composer,
musician, my other son, Michael,
is in Israel so he's a psychologist
and once I asked him, Michael,
isn't it true that I
was the perfect mother?
[Laughter] If he's a
psychologist it also say something
about his mother, yeah?
[Laughter] So, he was
thinking such a serious,
wonderful person and
he said, no, no, no.
I was so offended.
What do you mean?
I am an angel?
And then he said but I wouldn't
change you in the world.
So we are now okay and that, well,
you can be [inaudible] your mother.
So, then my children were
already grow up and not
at all home now I want to tell
you how it came that I started
to have this courage
to write this book
and I was already very established
as a writer for children very known
at home and abroad and so
on and then my mother died
and then my husband, the father of
my children, was ill and I took care
of him at home and I just
transferred him on my arms
to the other world, and I
was left alone with the cat
and the gold fish, the name of
the cat is Soromoro [phonetic]
and the name of the
gold fish is Alexander.
And well, it's not one gold fish
because usually they have
[inaudible] once in a while.
So, in our little garden I have
like kind of little mausoleum
for all those Alexanders,
Alexander the 1st and the 2nd
and now it's the 6th already,
but they are very nice pets.
First of all they are quiet, yeah?
Which is not bad.
And then they are very clean
also, which is not also so bad.
But then I was left alone at
home and I started to think
that maybe I will [inaudible]
I had this obligation to write
about this history of me
during the war and our family.
And I was sitting and
I don't enjoy writing,
only [inaudible] enjoy
writing, but I had just
like promised myself
that I would try.
First I wrote, if you are interested
you will find it in the book,
first I wrote like a letter
to myself being a little girl
and promising this little girl
because I just feel this little girl
in myself, you know, it's
this childhood everyone
that feels this childhood
inside his soul.
So my friend, [inaudible],
she's a poet in Israel,
she said that the childhood is like
an island in the middle of your life
and there are people that
have like a little boat
that they can visit their childhood
and those people do
not become bankers
or politicians, excuse
me, and martians.
They become teachers and doctors
and artists because they feel
that it is not easy to be a child.
Really it's very difficult
to be a child.
First of all you are short and
you do not have a credit card
and everyone is telling
you what to do.
So I have this ability to
visit myself as a child.
So first of all this letter to
myself promising this little girl,
promising I will never,
ever abandon you ever
because we will die together.
So it's this, you know, huge
question what is better to die
in the arms of a loving mother or
that your loving mother is trying
to somehow save you
like my mother did?
It's a big question I don't know.
So, well, I can tell you many things
but we do not have enough time.
So I just tell you that I
wrote this book and it became,
it get the bigger prize
for literature in Israel.
I was so surprised.
It's the [inaudible]
prize and it was very nice
because all the prizes I get
[inaudible] this piece of paper
and here all of a sudden
it was also some money,
not that the government didn't
took the taxes, of course,
which is really very nasty,
but then you could buy a car
and it wasn't so bad.
So, and this book I was
really surprised that people,
it got the prize not because
about what it's written
but the way it, the
literature prize.
And after the first book
I had this really courage
to write the second one
which is called [inaudible],
which means a teenager and this
one is about me coming to Israel
as a new immigrant from Poland
and it was horrible, very,
very difficult I must tell you.
I hope that it will also
be translated to English.
And the third one is called Ishiar
[phonetic], which means a woman,
and some stories of being a
witness to things in life as a woman
and now I am playing with hope that
maybe I will have enough courage
and patience to write
the fourth one,
and I want, I have a name already.
So I would call it matrona
[phonetic] which is, you know,
the Roman old lady's, old lady's
matron you must know this word.
So I, maybe.
I don't know.
So, now, well there are some things,
of course, that I can tell you
but if you're interested in reading
the book or just look at my site
on the Internet there are
many interviews with me
that you can hear some more things.
And now we, and now maybe some of
you have some questions about, ah,
yeah, this man is my partner and
is all the time criticizing me.
[Laughter] But, okay, so here
when we were, after the war
and we were saved by the Red Army,
I know that in America you used
to think that the Americans
won the war, but it is not true
because after Stalingrad
if you know about it,
it was after the Russians
were going to win the war
and then the Americans joined.
And I remember my father all the
time they were why it's not a
second front?
Why not second front?
So when we were after
the war it became,
my mother was very
ill with tuberculosis.
She almost died.
And my father broke an arm because
we couldn't work and I was brought
to some orphanage because
the war was going on.
It was on the east when
we were, when we were
and Poland to Berlin and to Berlin.
So I was in this orphanage
which was also hell,
but no one helped me
and it was enough food.
So, somehow my mother succeed not to
die because it was a mortal illness
if you know about, well, know
antibiotics and it's terrible
and then we went back to this birth
town Krakow, the beautiful Krakow,
which is this ridiculous hat
my mother is wearing of me
with this [inaudible] which became
horrible for me because people
from America after the war
they felt very guilty about all
of us survivors so few of
all the tens of thousands
of people that were murdered.
And they sent some packages
from America and you are America
so all kind of stupid
clothes and so one.
In one of the packages, it was this
stupid hat that when I wear it,
it always go up with this
stupid pom pom and to hold it
on my head I used to do like this.
And this [inaudible] stayed with
me with the head, without the head.
Some kind of a [inaudible]
but it stopped now.
And, well, but we had
to leave Poland
because of some threats anti-Semitic
and the only place we
could go was Israel.
My father didn't like the politics
of Israel and [inaudible] and so on.
He was a Communist.
He was like many good people he
believed that this is an idea
that would save the
world and also the Jews.
So, but we went to Israel
and here is some [inaudible]
on this horrible, terrible ship
Galea [phonetic] that we came
to Israel and it was
31 of December 1949.
And then next morning in
Tel Aviv it was snowing.
Never before and never after.
People went crazy.
And I was thinking, oh, wow, why did
they make such a fuss a little snow?
And another part became like
being somehow, you know,
Hebrew and it was very hard
for new immigrants in Israel.
Now to be a new immigrant in
Israel is horrible, difficult,
so this is the second book I write
about it and so we have [inaudible]
but you have some questions?
Maybe they have some questions?
>> Gail Shirazi: We have
time for 2 short questions.
Yes, hi?
[ Inaudible ]
The question is did you have
a hand in the translation
when Girl was being translated?
>> Alona Frankel: To
English you mean?
Because it's also in Polish.
No. No. Because I didn't
have [speaking Hebrew]?
>> Patience.
>> Alona Frankel: Yeah, but it was,
it turned out to be a
wonderful translation
and to Polish I have also
wonderful translator.
I asked Amos Oz about who
translate his book about Love and --
>> -- Love and Darkness.
>> Alona Frankel: Yes.
So he recommended some young man
that was a priest and he fell
in love with Hebrew and he stopped
to be a priest and he started
to be one of the most wonderful
translators from Hebrew to Polish.
So he also translated my
book Girl wonderfully,
but I didn't check
it because, well, I,
like I always have
something to do next.
So and I am a little
lazy also I think.
I trust them.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, she was wonderful.
Yeah. Yes, please?
>> Who me?
>> Alona Frankel: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Gail Shirazi: The
question was how old were you
when you drew these pictures
from the hiding place?
>> Alona Frankel: Yeah.
So, it was like in '43
and I was born in '37.
So, yeah. Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Gail Shirazi: The question
was can you say a few words
of what inspired you to be a
children's illustrator and author.
>> Alona Frankel: Well, this
is the only thing I can do
and get paid for.
[Laughter] I am kind of
dyslexic or something.
I write with mistakes, I do
not know the [speaking Hebrew]?
>> Multiplication.
>> Alona Frankel: Multiplication
and I really don't care.
[Laughter] And this was the only
thing and then the major, my love
and I think what saved really
my life were books and art.
Those are the things that
really there was to live for.
And the books saved my life.
I remember some years
not what happened around
but that I read Dickens or
Gargoyle [phonetic] or, you know,
so those 2 things the love for
books and the love for arts,
and I have a little talent also
and most important
thing I have been lucky.
It's very important
it's hard to realize
that sometimes life is
like, that you are lucky.
That this woman didn't abandon me,
that somehow people liked what I,
my work, which is also
I know so many people
in this world enormously talented
but they didn't have the something
that is really mysterious and
it's very hard to accept the fact
that luck is also,
you know, important.
>> Gail Shirazi: One more question.
>> Alona Frankel: This lady, please?
>> I was wondering I've been
reading about Oskar Schindler.
I was wondering if you or
your family knew [inaudible]?
>> Gail Shirazi: The
question was does anybody,
does Alona know anything
that worked with Schindler
or anybody that he saved?
>> Alona Frankel: Not at all, not
at all, but you can really realize
that I am this little
girl in the red coat,
but I survived and she didn't.
And, well, it's unbelievable.
I must tell you I like
to talk about it.
I didn't think that it really, I
somehow found, find the way to go
around it and not to ruin my life.
Maybe because I was always so amazed
by the wonders of nature and maybe
because in this place in the village
I remember I was the [inaudible]
geese, very stupid, embarrassing
I must tell you, and I took care
of the horse and I looked at all
the flowers and the [inaudible]
and everything and my best
friends were the pigs, you know,
because I was such a little girl.
So I used to crawl into
their [speaking Hebrew].
>> Pigsty.
>> Alona Frankel: Pigsty, yeah,
and I made for myself some dolls
of apple and corn, from the corn
hair, and they ate those dolls,
but still they are very
intelligent, lovely animals.
Not so [inaudible] but very,
very nice and they are not dirty.
They must have moisture
on their skin
so if you give them [inaudible],
they will bathe in [inaudible],
of course, but they
didn't have they have mud
and I like them very much really.
>> Gail Shirazi: Thank
you, Alona, very much.
[ Applause ]
You are really to be admired.
And we love you.
Thank you for coming.
>> Alona Frankel: Thank you all.
And you must understand that for
me it's all strange to be here.
The other day I also had some
talk in Harvard University,
and I do not have any [inaudible]
any certificate of anything
because I really didn't
study anything.
It doesn't mean that I do not
know anything, but so I was there
in this front yard of Harvard,
and I was thinking, wow,
2 big gentlemen will come and take
me on a jet and say Mrs. Frankel,
you do not have any
certificate or anything.
You can't stand on this
Holy ground of Harvard.
[Laughter] Please go out like
in the last scene in the trial
of [inaudible] you remember.
And I was there, I was talking to
people, they looked quite interested
and here I am it's like the temple
of the knowledge of the world
and you sit and you listen
to me and it's all nice.
This little girl, you know, all
this way so life is surprising,
and I would like it to continue and
let us all be healthy and happy,
okay, for the rest of [inaudible].
>> Gail Shirazi: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.